[Applause]
oh
oh the firewood's getting low
it's springtime here alaska for those
people who heat their homes with fire
their firewood supply is critically low
so we gotta go and get more firewood
before the rivers thaw out we can't get
to it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all righty
all right guys here we go is what we're
looking for dead spruce tree you can see
all the sap
this tree bled to death it was infested
with japanese spruce bark beetles it's
an invasive beetle here that's killing
like every third or fifth tree in this
forest there's a lot of standing dead
wood that's a big wildfire hazard in the
summertime we're going to thin that out
and get a year's supply of firewood all
in the same god
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
there we go trailer converts into a log
hauler
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh we're off to a great start but it's
lunch and i am starving so i'm gonna
grab some food on my back
i got some good stuff
all right i got some linghi mui covered
mango got some dates and i got a bunch
of cheese cheese is crazy high in
calories and doesn't take any cooking so
a great lunch time snack
i love ling hiemui seasoning and on
dried mango
it's amazing
this entire wedge of yarsburg is about 2
000 calories right here
it's insane
a little fig cake here it's got fig and
almonds in it
oh
um
that's good
all right time to get back to work
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh my goodness that's a lot of wood i
think it's time to start stacking some
more
so
hmm
[Music]
uh
we got a lot done today but we're not
done yet
i still gotta buck up all those logs
over there
but it's about an hour before sunset
so i'm just going to kind of get my bed
ready
we're spending the night here the wood
pile well i'm going to pick up all of
these misfit pieces we're going to use
them for our fire tonight and i'm going
to use some of these broken branches for
my bed
so
oh my goodness i am tired i got here
about nine o'clock 9 30 and it's 8
o'clock now i just barely stopped
working
it's been a long day
got a lot done
got a lot more to do
oh man i can feel the heat off that fire
it's just bouncing back off that wood
really coming at me
feels very nice just got to make sure i
don't light the walls on fire
my gloves are kind of wet i'll dry these
off
all right got my bed set up i'm gonna
get the fire stoked a little bit and uh
then eat some food
i might end up going to bed very early
today i am so tired well for dinner
got some french baguettes some spiced
apple butter and my massive pile of
cheese and dried fruit
peach rose hip herbal tea here
uh
ah a warm toasted baguette with some
melted roclette cheese and some apple
butter
i can hear a wolf out there
yeah there's a wolf howling behind me
and i think he's coming my way because
the howling keeps getting louder and
louder
i have to keep an eye out for him
i got food in me and a roaring fire is
keeping me warm it's late
but i've got to do one more thing before
i go to bed i got to dry my socks out
they're really wet and if i go to bed
with wet socks i'm going to have cold
feet
those are toasty warm
well it's late
and i'm tired so i'm gonna go to bed
i'll see you guys in the morning
ooh it's cold outside it got a lot
colder last night i better get this fire
going
well i've got a lot to do today and the
whole point of camping out here is to
get more done
but i don't have time to dawdle as soon
as i get warmed up i gotta make
breakfast get to work
we got some cut oats
and a butt ton of raisins
add a little bit of butter to it
still cut oatmeal with butter and honey
oh
all right guys i got breakfast in my
belly i need to get my bed all cleaned
up and all my stuff out of here and the
fire put out we gotta cut more firewood
we're gonna finish this shelter
so
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
ah
so
[Music]
this is really good apple butter
all right back to work
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shhh
my air filter is so dirty it's been
giving me trouble ever since i got here
but usually i just pop it out blow on it
knock it out
throw it back in it would work but this
time when i pulled it out there was dirt
all on the inside of the air intake so i
tried to wash out with some gasoline i'm
gonna let the gasoline evaporate we're
gonna see if we can get it to work
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well there you go not too shabby
oh
oh that's
so much flatter it's a lot more level
it'll be nice
[Applause]
not too bad i think that's going to be
pretty cozy tonight
but i'm just going to go ahead and get
my bed made up and uh kind of get
unpacked and
go see about dinner
yeah it's gonna be a good night
[Applause]
well this bed sure is a big improvement
holy mackerel
can you hear that
that's a whole pack of wolves
there's two over there
there's a couple over there and they
were a lot closer than they were last
night huh
there was a moose and a calf on the
trail down that way earlier today i
wonder if they're hunting that calf well
i think that's a sign that i need to get
everything ready for the night
sun's gonna set real real quick here but
i think we're going to be nice and safe
wolves or no wolves
that's about as sturdy of a shelter as
i've slept in a little while so
i think we'll be all right
some warm herbal tea feels nice it's
getting cold out there
temperature is dropping like the sun
well if you're wondering if bread cheese
and apple butter ever gets old the
answer is no it never gets old it's
awesome
we got some pork jowls here we're going
to cook that up
oh look at that
that is amazing
[Music]
well we'll just
put that over here
[Music]
oh that hits the spot that is so good
i got my shelter built the fire's going
got food in my belly
ah
it's gonna be a nice relaxing night it's
gonna work out okay
well it's late i'm tired
i'm gonna go to bed see you guys in the
morning
good morning whoo
gotta get this fire going because it is
cold
feels like it's about 20 degrees colder
than it was last night
it's got some proper nip in the air
we're gonna get this place warmed up
oh that's good
there you go guys a log cabin made out
of firewood rounds a little home away
from home while i'm cutting and bucking
firewood
but to give you some perspective this is
only about a two-month supply of
firewood to heat an alaskan home for an
entire year you're gonna need a lot more
wood than this
but
we gotta start hauling it out of here so
we're gonna go ahead
take this thing down
and start hauling wood and stacking it
up by the house
all right let's get to it
so
[Music]
so
so
oh it's gonna take a lot of trips let's
get going
[Music]
so
[Music]
well guys there is a lot of firewood to
haul and stack
i'm going to put the camera down and
call it for this video hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video if you want to
see more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel including our survival
camping videos check out our camping and
adventure playlist i'll put a link in
the video description below and make
sure to click subscribe because we put
out new videos every saturday morning
i'll see you then if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning hit that bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]